en el sexto distrito de la capital
centroafricana el agua y no ha salido de
los grifos desde hace más de cinco años
prince ya es estudiante en su familia
ella es la encargada de acarrear el agua
y esta es mi casa vivo con mis padres le
pago después de ir a clases en la
universidad regresa a su casa y debe
ocuparse de los bidones lo menos el agua
es vida estoy obligada a ir por ella
limpió la casa la 'u' los platos lavo la
ropa cocina la abuela de prince ya tuvo
que esperar hasta sus 40 años para ver
la construcción de pozos con bombas en
el barrio antes sólo tenían el río o
pequeños pozos artesanales tenías agua
antes cuando eras joven
se llevan a la sabana a buscar agua a
las aguas de la ciénaga del río eso era
lo que siente
esta tarde prince no tiene ni las
fuerzas ni el dinero para ir a llenar
los bidones entonces solo se lleva uno
para utilizarlo durante la tarde
cruza todo su barrio hasta llegar al
pozo más cercano a 500 metros de su casa
tiene prisa y debe regresar para
ocuparse de su abuela puedes llenar mi
vídeo en ahora mismo si no quieres
esperar traes tu bidón y paga 50 francos
el doble pero normalmente cuesta 25
francos al igual que prince a miles de
centroafricanos se agrupan delante de
los pozos en todos los barrios de la
ciudad en banco para obtener agua es
necesario salir a buscarla
para aquí está tu vida gustav un joven
estudiante de derecho administra el
punto de agua en su tiempo libre vende
el bidón de 20 litros a 25 francos cf a
lo que equivale a unos cuantos céntimos
de dólar y puede ganar hasta 8 dólares
al día es el pozo más barato del barrio
para alguien que vive aquí por ejemplo
si quiere tener agua de lazo de acá debe
bajar hasta 22 y luego ir hasta colocó
para obtenerla este pozo le permite a
las personas recortar trayectos y
obtener agua en tiempo normal
gustavo utiliza su dinero sobre todo
para pagar sus estudios y mantener el
pozo en buen estado
cada día se llenan cientos de bidones y
a veces no alcanza para todo el mundo
este único punto de agua aquí no es
suficiente para toda la población
solo hay una reserva de 500 litros y si
miles de vanquish van a los pozos cada
día es porque el agua que se bombea del
gran río centroafricano el ubangui ya no
es suficiente el agua llega aquí a
través de un canal de conducción
eric el director técnico vigila las
instalaciones de la empresa de agua para
él la estación seca es sinónimo de
problemas esta capacidad de captación ha
disminuido considerablemente hasta tal
punto que en un momento dado estábamos
cerca de expirar solo arena unos
kilómetros más lejos
erika va a la planta de tratamiento
construida en los años 70 la empresa
sólo puede distribuir la agua a menos de
la mitad de la capital sus equipamientos
son demasiado antiguos y no están
adaptados para una ciudad tan grande hay
que entender que en 1975 la ciudad de
bam bam era tan grande como ahora la
población se disparó y estamos alrededor
de 15 millones de habitantes entonces es
muy difícil darle agua a todo el mundo a
todo
vandalismo reservas de agua demasiado
escasas falta de electricidad para
alimentar las bombas la última avería
tras una tormenta duró más de 10 -cinco
porque vemos problemas a nivel de
nuestros grupos electrógenos ante el
menor problema hay una falta de agua el
banco africano de desarrollo el fondo
saudí y el banco mundial financian
nuevos equipamientos para las odeca con
varios millones de dólares pero mientras
se espera su instalación completa los
habitantes de banguí deben arreglárselas
unos kilómetros más lejos al borde de
las colinas hay un espectáculo fuera de
lo común y es un paso hacia la solución
este barrio del cuarto distrito nunca
había tenido pozos aunque tiene cuatro
mil habitantes una ong ruandés hay una
empresa india de desarrollo en este
proyecto de la alcaldía de banguí yo
estoy aquí desde 1980
realmente era el matorral hay que ir a
otros barrios que están alrededor para
obtener agua aquí comienza una gran
construcción de 50 pozos a lo largo de
la ciudad
el costo un millón de euros financiado
por la unión europea en un mes se habrá
construido una veintena de pozos
hay un rendimiento muy suficiente es más
o menos como un río que corre la capa
subterránea no está lejos y está llena
de agua sólo basta con cavar para
alcanzarla un proyecto inédito de en
banguí que debería permitirles a más de
100.000 personas adicionales acceder a
un agua potable cerca de sus casas para
final del año